oh i'd love to see your dog and you'd
say oh can you go bring your four dogs
in here probably not because it would be
total chaos
but i mean even on social media i'm
starting to put my dogs in the shot with
me because why not
let people really see who i am and what
i care about
[Music]
dana look arimoto thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
great thank you for asking it's been
quite a whirlwind
2020 we were supposed to do this last
week when the fires broke out in
california
so just as we thought uh you know we've
seen it all where it looks like there's
a little bit more coming but but but
we're doing it
i'm very thankful for being so generous
with your time and for being so flexible
sure first of all to start off you have
four dogs among them
15 legs only three of them can hear tell
tell me a little bit about your rescue
dogs
well they're rescues so like all of us
they are differently abled
one has three legs one can't hear and we
love them
all i love it what are their names leo
leilani scooter
and lily ah i love it
very very cute uh wonderful okay so dana
uh you know before we get
to talk about but some of the topics
that we discussed that that i think are
going to be fascinating whether
it's about gender equality or or
work-life balance
i'd love to hear a little bit about your
journey because you've done so many
different things
from you know being on advisory boards
to creating organizations to
to now coaching a leadership
different leaders and leadership styles
to to speaking engagements
so who's who who are you and and what
motivates you
i am clearly someone with a dd and uh
someone who likes to experiment and i'm
i'm definitely
motivated and inspired by making an
impact on the world and
so in a lot of ways having hired and
trained
develop mentored thousands of people
over 20 some years
primarily in silicon valley i feel like
you know i can honestly say i have made
a difference however i have a real
impatience for action
which is also very silicon valley and so
i would like to help more people
universally and that's kind of the
mission i'm on now what what is that so
what does that even mean that you're
coaching and helping people whether it's
in silicon valley or elsewhere but
what does that mean for you to to help
make an impact by helping others
yeah so one of the reasons i
dabble in so many different methods and
mediums having a book
now and a podcast and posting an
instagram and having
a full executive coaching practice with
c-suite members of different kinds of
companies including founder-led
companies
it gives me a chance to really work in
different ways with different people
some short term some long term some
quick hit some
you know really over horizon work and
strategy so
i have all these different vantage
points of working with individuals and
helping them with where they want to go
so you know you're looking at at all
these hundreds or thousands of people
that you're saying
give me some things that that that often
come up what are some things that
oftentimes
you see pattern recognition and you're
saying ah i've seen this before i'm
seeing this type of behavior i'm seeing
this type of thing that
then maybe if i look at that case study
i can bring that in and help
for sure so people confuse management
with leadership
every single day and there's a clear and
distinct difference
and i'm really interested in helping
people with leadership whether they're
the leader of their life
the leader at work the leader in their
marriage the leader in their career
their leader in their education
uh i really am interested in helping
people lead
and and so you mentioned that book that
that er that you've written so tell me a
little bit about that and how that ties
into this work
with mentorship and coaching yeah so
i hit my head pretty hard many times and
i guess i'm a slow learned
in terms of work life balance and
believing i can have it all by doing it
all all
at one time and of course women in
particular in silicon valley we have all
these great muses
who make it look like that's possible
well the truth is it's not we actually
all have limits
and without serious help serious
outsourcing
serious financial wherewithal etc etc
it's really not possible to have it all
all at one time and so
what i've really learned and proven over
time and now i'm helping others to
figure out for themselves and their
organizations
is that you have to give something up to
get what it is you really want and most
people don't even
ask themselves what is it i really want
situationally
and relatively right so i mean when
every time like we say work life balance
immediately
you know the the 21st century has given
rise to this idea of work-life balance
and a lot of different people
are talking about it you know throughout
high school and the the mantra that my
principal had was balance balance
balance
everybody's talking about balance and
you know as a go-getter myself i can
testify you know there's 24 hours in a
day
sometimes i feel like i have like i'm
like any minute that i'm doing something
i feel like i'm missing out on that
other thing
talk to me a little bit about your take
on this work-life balance what does it
take to really succeed and what does it
mean to be
authentic enough with yourself to to be
able to forgo some other things that
maybe the social norm won't really let
you yeah so the social norm is a big
part of it i'm glad you brought that up
so there's these shoulds
you should do this you shouldn't do that
and someone also might be someone you
emulate or your muse or your role model
or your mentor
and you think oh they do it this way so
i should too well
one size never fits all one size only
fits one so there's five key areas of
life that we all share universally
and they are career family friendships
community and your own well-being and so
what happens when you're constantly
running
like a hamster sprinting inside of a
marathon in this wheel on this
teeter-totter you might hit balance for
a moment
but it comes with a really high cost and
then you're usually depleted exhausted
sick
in some cases like i talked about in my
book and you roll out of the wheel
and then you kind of like hit reset and
you get right back in the wheel we don't
do anything different
it sounds like you just start running
you sound like you're alluding to some
specific example that i'd love to hear
sure i used to get pneumonia one to
three times
per year pneumonia one to three times
per year yep
like clockwork really pattern
recognition
predicting predictably i would know it
was coming
and still work myself it was seasonal
based on how much work you had
yep and so okay so tell me about this
experience you're getting pneumonia
seasonally two or three times a year you
realize that it's part of your work i'm
guessing that you're still working very
hard you're allowing yourself to get
pneumonia for quite some time right
yes years years and years you know it's
like this
total type a overachiever single mom at
the time
uh really thought i was striving for
something
not realizing and it's a little corny
but it is the journey it's not the
destination
and if you are someone who's very
motivated
very high achieving you know there's no
destination because there's another
mountain to climb anywhere right
and no one says let me sprint the
marathon 100
and then they win 100 i remember vividly
my
my family and i we were climbing mount
kilimanjaro
last year and it was one of the hardest
things i've ever done in my life and
as we reached the peak we were telling
ourselves the entire eight days there's
no way we're ever doing this thing again
this is awful we're
in so much pain the second we hit the
bus down
at the bottom of the mountain we're like
okay so everest next year like what's
happening so you know
covet hit so maybe that's one of the
reasons why we didn't go for that but
but i can totally feel
what you're saying so now that you're on
you know you're helping
others understand this through the book
what are you what are you saying then so
what what is
the solution because i know for myself i
will not be satisfied
if i if i do less work
all things are not created equal so what
i suggest is that you actually choose
what you want to work on what you want
to spend time on
and the derivative the the delta of the
equation
is joy productivity and value so if i
say to you
you can have all three that's your
triple threat joy productivity and value
but you can't do all things equally at
all times on any given day
especially inside of a week i really
encourage you to look at your week's
production 168 hours in a week we all
have the same amount of time you can't
buy more
then you might think differently about
okay do i want to spend more time in
career more time with family
our career and family my top and then
i'm willing to trade off a little bit
on community and maybe friendships but
what about your well-being
what about you and taking care of
yourself because when we come last
there's nothing to give right right so
then
i mean these are definitely not things
that we can do alone right i mean i
i don't think that i could really be
honest with myself sitting down because
you know there's so many different pools
and so many different
uh so many different things that that
bring you into different areas so how do
how do people go
about that so i have a free quiz on
settlesmarter.com
quiz and it gives you at least a
very quick very simple five minutes or
less baseline as to where you
are when no one else is looking so you
take this quiz
it's not you know it can be anonymous it
doesn't have to be but it's not going to
get shared with anyone but yourself
and so you know depending on how
explicit you are with yourself you
figure out where
am i actually spending time versus
where do i really want to spend time so
the quiz forces you
to make decisions and trade-offs and
then it gives you a little bit of like a
a spider graph of where you're at versus
where you want to be at
and then there's some tips and tricks
and tools and traps to avoid on how to
get there
definitely definitely so what is what
what patterns have you been
seeing at least with the work that
you're doing in terms of people's
ability to find this balance or or if
it's helping their work or
tendering their work because obviously
there's so much connectivity here with
their with their inner well-being their
physical health with the work they're
doing how does it all come come together
yeah i like to say harmony beats balance
every time
and harmony is what you get when you
integrate it's when we
compartmentalize or separate ourselves
or pretend we're one person at one
work and one person at home and
especially in kovid
we all see everyone all the time it's
not like i don't see
your kitchen behind you right now i do
and it's not like you don't see my sign
that i forgot
to put away and it's if i if you saw a
little lower my camera you'd be like oh
your credentials are on the ground well
that's because my social media
said take them off the wall and i have
flowers but i wouldn't normally have
flowers
so we're just revealed we're just
ourselves we're just human and so when
we stop compartmentalizing so much
and we start making those conscious
trade-offs things start to really shift
for us
and we can really feel that joy
productivity and value
so now you're we're saying like we're
entering code renting your new reality
of of
where it's not even work-life balance
but the the line between life and work
is so blurred
that in one moment i'm sitting here and
like you said if we look at the camera
just a little bit there i have my dog
sitting right next to me and it's
it's play time in about five minutes
right when this is over so
so how do we how do we balance this this
whole arena
we we talk about it and i would say to
you what are you gonna play with your
dog oh i'd love to see your dog and
you'd say oh can you go
bring your four dogs in here probably
not because it would be total chaos
but i mean even on social media i'm
starting to put my dogs in the shot with
me because
why not let people really see who i am
and what i care about
and that's where rapport building and
mirroring and alignment and fully
understanding each other comes from is
finding something of commonality this is
what the number one thing is in dealing
with gender issues
with dealing with diversity equity and
inclusion issues find something in
common
like if you are wearing glasses right
now and i'm wearing glasses right now we
could say we both have glasses
who cares that you're younger than i am
and a guy and i'm older than you are and
a woman
who cares we both have glasses you don't
have glasses so that that fell apart
there but you know not yet it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen sooner rather
than later
but you're mentioning gender gender
equality or inequality and
diversification
give me a give me a two or two cents on
on both those subjects
first seek to understand before seeking
to be understood
that's it solves everything
clarify a little bit what what do you
mean by that
have you heard of the golden rule i i i
have and i've heard of the platinum rule
which i believe you're going to allude
to right
i thought i invented the platinum rule i
can't prove it
but i put that into place in a company
in 1999
and you were probably way better at
research than i am so i'm gonna actually
ask you to trade me this back
and tell me did that come out before 99
if not
i missed the boat i should have coined
that we're gonna have to so the golden
yes go ahead no no what is the golden
rule in the platform rule
the golden rule which comes apparently
from the bible i'm spiritual not
religious however
the golden rule is do unto others as
you'd have done unto you
the platinum rule is doing to others as
they'd have done unto them
if you don't know what somebody wants
you need to understand it
before you try to get them to see it
your way
and because we're talking silicon valley
and everything agile
i will add the equation for speed and
enhancement of performance is one plus
one equals three
that's the collaborative model which is
your ideas and experience and mine
together
are moving us further faster right
that's how collaboration works but if
i were to just really try to push my
agenda on you
that's the golden rule so as you're
talking to
leaders c-suite executives uh
what how how do you help them cope with
you know this new era obviously
2020 gave light to a lot of issues that
are present not just in the united
states but in the world in general
the metoo movement over the past few
years the black lives matter movement
so what's happening now as you're
observing with the leadership scene and
what some what are some practical things
that
as a leader myself or my friends or
anybody else who wants to become a good
leader
what can we do to improve so the first
thing is something that i'm leading by
example on again because i firmly
believe
and i can prove it that people follow
what you do now what you say
so i don't do diversity equity and
inclusion
training anymore i'm white and i don't
do it
i refer it to people of color some women
some men but people of color because
it's very hard to
coach or teach anything where you can't
possibly walk in those shoes i mean look
we're all in the same storm
but we're definitely in different boats
and you cannot
ever assume you can relate to someone or
step in their shoes or be where they've
been if you haven't
and it's a really slippery slope so for
leaders in particular
i had i had a client this morning say
we'd love you to do de ni work and i
said no i'm white i'm not doing it but
here's a couple people to choose from
you pick
but i love all of them that i'm
referring you to and
most of these particular leaders that
i'm thinking about recently are also
white
and it's sometimes a little bit of an
eye-opener they're like but i don't
understand like you're our coach why
wouldn't you do that work and you and
your woman it's like
i'm a white woman of privilege whether
i've earned it or not
doesn't matter and so i think it's
really time
to really raise this bar
and that means we have to do something
and that's my something
i love it that's that that is very very
inspiring so i love this from the last
few minutes that we have to get to know
a little you a little bit better and
what really motivates you because
over the years having done so much and
ha and being so in tune with the things
that make you happy
and helping others achieve that
fulfillment and understanding of where
their joy productivity and and and sort
of
balances like what so what what are you
what do you really get excited about
uh helping others that want to
change the world so that i'm not feeling
so much like i'm doing a lot of this on
my own it's too slow
and you also mentioned that you are a
little adhd
with it with the in the fact that you're
you're a little impatient to wait for it
to happen right
uh always so how does that how does that
come into play do you is it
so do you work with a lot of different
people so that you can experience a lot
of different journeys and by the time
you move on to the next journey the
first one will have caught up and got to
work
that's a great question yeah there's
also a spectrum i've identified i
actually have this sort of
self-named protocol about how i coach
there's a guide process an evolve
process
and a master process because your life
is a gem and it's multifaceted and
that's gem
and some people pace through the guide
piece which is training wheels really
really fast others it can be years
some people get through sort of like i'm
wobbly but the training wheels are off
that's the evolve process really fast
others are years
master is i'm an autopilot and i no
longer have to think about
oh i'm going to turn left i push the
blinker down on the car
and that's where i want everyone to get
and then they've probably outgrown me or
they can just check in occasionally for
maintenance or whatever
and i'm cool with that and not all
coaches are cool with that i i don't
need to coach people for life
what does that mean to to coach so let's
go back a little bit
and and go up you know 30 000 feet in
the air why do executives and leaders
need
a coach because you know you know the
average person thinks of a leader a
big-time ceo or
you know we're thinking politicians oh
they've had they have it together they
know everything they're
moral they know exactly what needs to
happen but it's not always the case is
it
no and it certainly wasn't for me when i
hired my first coach which was when i
was helping a founder grow and exit her
business
um two heads are always better than one
i've always found that to be true
no one knows everything about anything
yeah and the sounding board
even if you have a fantastic board of
directors
sometimes you just need to vent you need
structured venting
and you need a sounding board who then
may help you get back to solutions and
options so
i am an avid believer and not just
because that's what i do for a living i
i had
a very serious coach my last company
before i defected from
corporate america is it difficult
sometimes for leaders to hire a coach
and to start the process feeling that
they're maybe giving up some of that
you know ego or control they had before
or they thought they had
that's a really good question yes and
i'm really clear i do what's called a a
fit call
before i coach anyone it has to be
mutual we have to be on the same page
and if you're not self-aware
and if you don't want to shift and you
don't want to transform in an
accelerated way i am absolutely not the
coach for you
i'm all for healthy ego but super
inflated ego
i'm a pretty tough coach with i'm pretty
good at getting that back in check
fragile ego i don't coach people with
fragile egos what is that what does that
mean fragile eagle
uh sometimes it's a victim thing it's a
super hyper critical thing
it's uh poor me look what the world's
done to me but here i am with this like
pile of money and or big title like
i just i don't have the patience for it
interesting
i'm also a mom so that's the mom card
i love it i love it okay now before we
leave i want to be a
i want to thank you again first of all
for being so generous with your time and
being so flexible with all that's
happened
uh it's this is definitely very very
insightful and very interesting both
talking about the work life balance and
and mainly i'm i'm thinking from this
being honest with yourself and being
and you know it's it's difficult to race
and especially you know coming
in and and at stanford and in silicon
valley there's so much happening and
there's so many different opportunities
and
it's very easy to lose track there's
only 24 hours in the day
and it might make sense to even spend
five or six hours of them sleeping my
girlfriend definitely
is we're having our daily struggles with
that and and she
needs to she needs to win more often but
but before we leave i have to ask you
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself and why those three
words
you won't be surprised tenacious
impatient and universally minded
i love it why those three
i've always been known even in my last
two companies ago
global group i was running they called
me tenacious d because i just
will not give up i am such a firm
believer that if something needs to be
done
i'll get it done it doesn't matter if
it's a mountain that needs to be moved
or a hill if i believe it i'll do it if
i don't believe it i also won't do it
as i enter my early 50s here i won't do
it if i don't believe it and that's new
for me
i used to do things i didn't believe in
because i thought i was holding the
company line or whatever but
not anymore i just will only do what i
believe in and i'm going to do it with a
lot of
tenacity i love it and i have other two
two more words that i need explanation
for impatience
it's probably the 80d it's probably a
little bit of silicon valley
um and also boredom frankly
my mind works fast and so
i get bored and that's usually not good
and finally the last word yeah
universally minded
since i was born i mean as long as i can
remember i've been crusading fighting
for the underdog
causes kind of grew up that way in
wisconsin where i was raised before i
came out here to the great
bay area and uh i do believe that we can
make a dent in the universe
and do good i do believe in being
socially conscious 100 it sounds like
that's exactly what you're doing whether
it's you know by helping others achieve
that or by spreading your message and
and i definitely hope that this will
also help be insightful for others
it definitely was for me thank you very
very much again for being so generous
with your time
and stay safe and stay healthy same to
you and your listeners thank you
thank you